i've recommended your book to so many
people and it's life-changing but i
guess the opening question just to get
some guys
who maybe don't know the story behind
your book is what made you want to write
a book called no more mr nice guy
all right i that's because i was a nice
guy
i was one of the people that needed the
book you know like your friend
and uh you know i thought that was a
great thing i thought i'm a nice guy i'd
tell people that 30 years ago i would
i would have brag i'm a nice guy i i i'm
different than other men
i'm not a jerk i treat women well
i'm generous i'm kind i avoid conflict
and i thought that was all really good
stuff until my second wife
told me one day i i can't take you
anymore you've got to go get help
and i go what do you mean you know
you're the one that's angry all the time
and moody and upset i'm i'm
i do everything to try to make
everything right i can't take your
passive aggressiveness
anymore i had i already had a phd in
marriage and family therapy
and i didn't even know what that meant
right let me get this right so you have
a phd
marriage in therapy marriage and family
therapy correct
and she's telling you i can't stand your
passive aggressiveness
and i didn't know what she meant and and
she said everybody thinks you're such a
nice guy
but you're not so nice to me you hurt me
you do hurtful things you
embarrass me in public you you bring up
things you
you think you're teasing but it hurts
and said you need to go get help
and said i'm going to leave you if you
don't so i mean that was like a big
stick upside the head so
i went i went to go get help to find out
why my why
me being a nice guy didn't make her
treat me better and didn't make her
appreciate
me and want to have sex more luckily i
landed in some good spots i landed in a
12-step
group and then the therapist and then i
joined a men's group and realized
that me being quote a nice guy
was um it was a put on i i i was trying
to win
people's love and approval and trying to
avoid
any kind of disapproval so i was really
uh
uh on on it on authentic
and uh wasn't particularly very honest
and and was
a difficult person to be around now how
tough is it for you
to have a phd in you know marriage and
you know for you to go to therapy to say
listen i need help on my marriage how
how embarra how tough was that for you
to do at that time well
it was challenging because um yeah
i grew up in a real fundamental
christian church my father was critical
i kind of grew up during the feminism
that
all men are bad and all this so i grew
up really hiding
everything about myself and that's
pretty typical of nice guys we keep a
lot of things in we hide a lot of things
we only show people enough of what we
think will make them approve of us or
not disapprove
so it was challenging but i tell you
what i i
loved it actually that group i mentioned
i went to was a 12-step group for sex
addicts
because my wife kept saying you're a sex
addict so i went to a 12-step group for
sex addicts and quickly found out i was
not a sex
addict i wasn't having enough sex to be
a sex addict
but these guys that were there man their
lives were really
messed up and and i i just went as this
group met like at six a.m every
once a week i got excited about going to
this group at six a.m
because for the first time in my life i
got to just open up
i got to just talk about me and reveal
me and let
and let out what i've come to to know is
toxic shame
this belief that i'm not good enough i'm
not lovable and
that was so just liberating to go
and just say hey i thought about this or
i have this dark
you know part of me or i did this thing
in the past or i want to go do this
thing
and the guys just go thanks for sharing
robert and i'm going wow that wasn't bad
at all
and and i got in with a good therapist
um and i got later got into a good men's
group
and i mean it takes work if you're used
to hiding parts of yourself
it is a challenge but that's the one
thing i say i
i repeat to every everybody you know
they're in the book
go find safe people to do this work with
go find somebody you can start
revealing yourself to talking to getting
more accurate feedback
of who you are and who you're not robert
let me ask you when your wife said you
need to go see somebody because i think
you're sex addict was she saying that
and was she saying that because you
constantly wanted to have sex with her
well she said that because you were
promiscuous
there was two pieces one is yes i wanted
to have sex with her and
and she we had a highly sexual
relationship before we got married and
on our honeymoon she said aren't you
glad that now that we're married we
don't have to pretend to like sex
anymore
i thought wait a minute i wasn't
pretending you know
you're hot you're sexy you're amazing i
mean and so
so she just like shut down sexually so
yeah i did
keep pursuing her for sex and then i did
act out
i had an inappropriate relationship with
a woman that she found out about
and um and she said you got to go get
help and and
i said that was the big stick upside my
head because if it wasn't for that
i'd still probably be doing that same
kind of stuff i was doing back then
[Music]